l'invention ne consiste pas à créer à
partir du néant mais à partir du chaos
d'un côté il y un créateur mary shelley
mary watson kraft william godwin bercy
chez des victor frankenstein de l'autre
la créature frankenstein ou le mythe du
prométhée moderne son monstre l'histoire
de mary ses sentiments son oeuvre sa
postérité
la créature et raccommoder assemblé à
partir d'une multitude de pièces d'idées
d'inspiration et d'expérience la vie de
mary shelley a construit fang einstein
nous allons reconstruire ici la vie de
mary shelley mairie worlds and craft
godwin est né le 30 août 1790 est près
de londres
j'ai déjà raconté dans mon précédent
gentes dames badass l'avis de ses
parents sa mère cugnière du féminisme
anglais moeurs dix jours après sa
naissance
ls avec son père et sa demi soeur née
d'une précédente relation de sa mère son
père se remarie par la suite ce qui lui
vaut une nouvelle demi soeur clare
claremont dont elle est très proche
elle a la chance de grandir dans une
famille favorisée même si elle ne fait
pas partie de la bourgeoisie et surtout
en plein dans le milieu intellectuel et
littéraire de l'époque son père et
éditeurs et possède une bibliothèque
impressionnante qui permet à mérida
prendre très tôt le latin le grec le
français l'italien
il veille à ce que ses enfants est une
bonne éducation en leur enseignant à
domicile et reçoit de nombreux auteurs
et philosophe qui renforce l'ouverture
d'esprit de mairie dans une lettre il
dit d'elle
je tiens à ce qu'elle soit élevée comme
une philosophe ou voir comme une cynique
mairie grande est cependant dans l'ombre
de ses deux personnages son père auquel
elle voue une grande admiration et sa
mère dont il entretient la mémoire la
perte de sa mère puis les nombreux des
séquelles subies autour d'elle tout au
long de sa vie en font une femme au
coeur fréquemment brisé parfois très
éloquente puis soudain mélancolique
détestant se donner en spectacle et
éprouvant souvent le besoin de se mettre
à l'abri du monde comme sur la tombe de
sa mère où elle se rend souvent mairie à
16 ans lorsqu'elle rencontre percy
shelley
il vient d'une famille aristocratique
avec laquelle il est en froid comme
beaucoup d'un resto qui ne se conforment
pas à la vie tracé par leurs parents et
fréquente la librairie de son père dont
il admire beaucoup le travail très vite
c'est le coup de foudre
mais le père de mes tantes de la
dissuader de cette relation elle s'y est
mariée même s'il ne vit plus avec sa
femme qui est enceinte de surcroît
d'un autre côté ses parents ont
longtemps avancé des idées très libérale
à l'encontre du mariage et mairie et
tenter de suivre leurs traces percy lui
prône l'amour libre polyamour qui ne
porte pas encore ce nom et aimerait
entraîner mairie dans cette idée il
s'enfuit donc en 1814
alors que mary a à peine 17 ans avec sa
soeur claire qui les accompagne tout au
long de leur histoire ils seront
partagés entre un désir de révolte de
liberté mais aussi une recherche de
conformité mais lui n'a aucun problème à
vivre avec un homme marié mais ne
supporte pas qu'il aille voir ailleurs
les ménages à plusieurs elles adhèrent à
ces idées d'amour libre mais ne cherche
pas être avec quelqu'un d'autre que lui
bien qu'il encourage à fréquenter
d'autres hommes
elle veut des enfants mais doit
supporter le fait que la femme légitime
de persil accouche d'un fils alors
qu'elle perd trois des quatre enfants
qu'elle a avec mais aussi en cela elle
se rapproche de sa mère défenseuse des
condition féminine mais qui meurent en
accouchant et qui se voit avance a
obligé de se marier pour légitimer sa
fille face à la société la société ne
voit d'ailleurs pas d'un meilleur oeil
la vie de mary pepsi est clair alors il
voyage en france en allemagne et en
italie que mary aime beaucoup les années
passant elle est de plus en plus
déprimée par la perte de ses deux autres
enfants
son seul fils à atteindre l'âge adulte
naissant en 1819 par le comportement de
persil vis-à-vis des autres femmes
elle accepte le fait qu'il fréquente
d'autres femmes qu'elles et devient même
ami avec l'une d'elle mais elle supporte
même qu'il leur dédier des poèmes
d'autres deuil viennent obscurcir ce
tableau le suicide de fanny sa demi
soeur et de la femme de percy qui leur
permettent ou même de se marier en 1816
à l'été 1822 alors qu'ils sont en italie
persie et décide d'acheter un voilier
avec des amis et de partir vers la
toscane le temps est mauvais s'il ne
sait pas nager sont retrouvés sur une
plage du jour plus tard il est incinéré
sur la plage et mary conserve son coeur
jusqu'à sa mort littéralement
durant tout le reste de sa vie elle
porte le deuil de persil ses derniers
mots dans le journal qu'elle tenait
depuis sa fuite en 1814 son push et les
pourquoi m'as tu abandonné dans tous ses
romans et plus encore après la mort de
peur si on retrouve cette idée de deuil
et de solitude
comme dans son dernier roman le dernier
et rome alors mon post apocalyptique
décrivant le dernier homme au monde
elle arrête d'écrire en 1839 après avoir
achevé son oeuvre
la publication des oeuvres complètes et
annoté de percy shelley qui contribue
grandement à faire connaître ses écrits
mais ne manque-t-il pas une certaines
créatures à cette histoire me direz vous
j'ai choisi de vous parler de toute son
histoire avait peur si en premier pour
mieux vous situer les sentiments de
mairie est la nature de leur relation
mais revenons un petit peu en arrière
nous sommes en 1816 sur les bords du lac
de genève
à cette époque c'est un lieu de
résidence réputé pour les anglais
marginaux à la vie scandaleuse et
rockstar d'aujourd'hui et le groupe qui
passe l'été au bord du lac rentre tout à
fait dans ses critères persie se
droguent mère et lui ne sont toujours
pas mariés
lord byron qui les invite est un
aristocrate et poète à la réputation
tellement sulfureuse qu'il est obligé de
quitter l'angleterre qualité d'être
ouvertement bisexuelle
ils sont accompagnés de claire et de
john polidori amende de byron tous les
deux ou seulement clair ça ne l'est pas
clair l'été s'annonce joyeux fait de
promenade en bateau sur le lac de
randonnée en montagne mais la météo en
décide autrement
tel est particulièrement horrible cet
été là on est en plein dans le petit âge
glaciaire et l'éruption d'un volcan en
indonésie contribué à perturber le
climat l'atmosphère autour de la villa
tourne donc à l'orage littéralement et
symboliquement byron très polis doré
comme son souffre-douleur et se
disputent régulièrement avec lui avec
claire aussi dont il s'éloigne il visait
cependant certains lieux qui inspire
mairie par la suite le glacier du
mont-blanc un laboratoire d'expériences
sur l'électricité et deux ans plus tôt
mairie avait aussi visité un certain
château en bavière ayant appartenu à une
famille frankenstein
mais le groupe s'ennuie rien n'est plus
pénible à l'esprit humain après que les
sentiments étaient surexcités par une
succession rapide d'événements que le
calme plat de l'inaction
pour passer le temps à la villa le
groupe lit des romans gothiques en
brûlant ce qu'il juge mal écrit jusqu'à
ce que byron propose une idée un
concours d'écriture
chacun devra écrire une histoire de
fantômes qu'ils pourront lire ensemble
et éventuellement publiés byron veut
écrire une histoire de vampires même le
bois du vin d'opium pour trouver
l'inspiration
elles se servent beaucoup de ses rêves
comme source d'idées pour ses histoires
et puis elle se met à écrire les jours
suivants et ne s'arrête plus persil
encourager la convaincre de faire de sa
nouvelle
un roman finalement de ce concours
claire et persil n'écrivent rien
byron ne rédigent que quelques notes sur
le mythe du vampire que polidori reprend
par la suite pour écrire le premier
roman vampirique anglais mais qu'il lui
apporte aucune contre à la fin de l'été
byron continue vers l'italie
les autres rentrent en angleterre et
marie continue d'écrire qu'elle publie
finalement frankenstein ou le huit du
prométhée moderne en 1818 qui rencontre
un succès immédiat
le concours de byron est un prétexte qui
plonge mairie dans une atmosphère
propice à l'écriture mais il est
probable que mairie aurait écrit
frankenstein quoi qu'il en soit puisque
ce sont tous les éléments de sa vie qui
ont formé la jeunesse de ce livre des
poètes marginaux réunis à l'été 1816
seul claire et mère lui survive john
polidori se suicident en 1821 peur s'ils
meurent noyés comme on l'a déjà vu et
lord byron moeurs de fièvre en grèce en
maudit soit le jour où j'ai reçu l'avis
et jurent les maudit sois mon créateur
même toi qui m'as fait je te dégoûte
dieu a créé l'homme à son image mais moi
je suis la forme corrompus de la tienne
plus horrible même s'attend à des
compagnons pour l'admirer le suivre moi
je reste de solitaire aie aie
le premier roman de mary shelley a été
construit à partir d'un tas de matériaux
existants
pour ce qui est des courants littéraires
on y retrouve une forte influence
gothique évidemment mais dont elle se
détache en écrivant par exemple son
roman à la première personne ce qui
rapproche le lecteur des personnages et
de leurs angoisses
tel est aussi à rapprocher des récits de
voyages des contes philosophiques et
même des romans de science fiction dont
frankenstein serait l'ancêtre elle
emprunte aussi à des mythes existants
celui de prométhée auquel le titre fait
directement référence est le paradis
perdu de milton que le monstre lie au
point de s'identifier aux personnages de
satan
comme son monstre son roman à couture et
de différentes influences ancien tout en
s'ancrant dans la science moderne
elle fait référence à darwin et surtout
aux travaux d'électricité galvanique
très en vogue à l'époque qui montre que
la matière vivante réagi à l'électricité
au début du 19e siècle des expériences
étaient réalisés sur des cadavres
d'animaux ou de condamnés pour provoquer
des mouvements et on en venait à se
demander si la résurrection serait un
jour possible par ce biais outre le
château qu'elle avait visité en bavière
frankenstein pourrait alors faire
référence à franklyn l'inventeur du
paratonnerre
elle tire donc son récit de sa propre
expérience à partir des voyages qu'elle
a réalisée en allemagne en suisse en
italie mais aussi à partir de son
approche de la mort et du deuil qui va
expérimenter de près à plusieurs
reprises
on le retrouve dans le sentiment de
solitude qui parcourt toutes ces oeuvres
de frankenstein a de l'asthme à
l'honneur mais aussi dans des histoires
d'amour impossible qu'elle met en scène
entre victor et elisabeth entre le
créateur et la créature on peut ainsi
faire beaucoup de parallèles entre son
roman et sa propre vie tej demande et
créateur de me produire fait elle dira
son monstre tout en dédiant son récit à
son père william godwin la première
personne tuée par le monstre se nomme
aussi william tout comme aurait dû
s'appeler le fils de goodwin et
milestone kraft s'il avait eu un fils à
la place de mairie lorsque frankenstein
et publié le décrit comme bailly deux
progénitures que je jette maintenant
dans le monde et il fait de même dire à
victor à propos de sa création
je ne voyais en sait peut-être que mon
propre vampires
lorsqu'il sort en 1818 frankenstein et
publié anonymement le public pense
d'abord que l'auteur est passé chez les
puisque c'est lui qui en signe la
préface
et puisque le roman est dédié à william
godwin le mentor de persil on a du mal à
croire que ce roman aurait pu être écrit
par une femme
et surtout on trouve ça dommage parce
qu'une telle histoire l'éloignent
fortement de la douceur inhérente à son
sexe on dit qu'elle est sous l'influencé
de son père de persil et tous ses autres
ouvrages porte simplement la mention par
l'auteur de frankenstein son père refuse
pendant très longtemps qu'elles signent
sous le nom de mary shelley
on l'appelle parfois par le nom de sa
mère est elle le signe sous son propre
nom qu en 1844 après la mort de son père
malgré ses sept romans ses comptes ses
récits ses nouvelles
les journaux qu'elle tenait la vie de
mary reste longtemps occultée par
frankenstein son premier roman et ses
autres ouvrages restent peu connus
jusqu'à la fin du xxème siècle jusqu'au
bout fiction et réalité se mêle dans sa
vie le monstre qu'on appelle souvent
frankenstein à tort au culte et dépasse
son créateur et le roman frankenstein
occulte mary shelley
[Musique]